Today, we are talking about
bonding between molecules.
Now, we have talked a lot
about bonding within molecules.
Right.
And that got us to
saying things like,
well you can use
electronegativity,
You can use electronegativity,
for example, to say,
I got an ionic bond.
All right.
Or I got a non-polar
covalent bond
or I've got a polar
covalent bond.
But today, what
we're going to do
is talk about how
these molecules--
how these molecules
bond together.
What sorts of interactions
can they have?
And those are really important.
Right.
So that's going to be the topic.
Now, if we just get started with
what we know what's up there.
All right.
Well, there's ionic.
So listen, I'm going
to fill this in.
Bond, a model.
You'll see what I mean.
I'm going to draw
a little cartoon.
The attraction,
how it's attracted,
the energy range,
and an example.
Right.
So for an ionic bond,
we've got ionic--
ionic.
OK.
And here we go.
Watch this.
Plus and minus--
there's my model.
OK.
And the attraction here--
we'll get a little specific.
It's a cation and an anion.
And we know that that's going
to go like Coulomb's Law.
Right.
So the attraction, the energy,
not the force, the energy
will go like 1 over R, roughly.
Now, what is the energy?
Well, the energy is
pretty wide ranging.
I'm going to do this
in kilojoules per mole,
since those are
the units I have.
I'll write that in a second.
And an ionic bond can have
lots and lots of range in here.
And it typically
can be very strong.
Something we've
already talked about.
An example would be sodium
chloride, right there.
Let's put the units here.
The energy units are in--
I'm going to write it here--
kilojoules per mole.
Now, in a covalent bond--
so covalent wouldn't be here.
OK.
So in a covalent
bond, remember, we've
got something very different.
We've got this carrying
a sharing kind of thing,
and we've got maybe two atoms.
Right.
Two atoms like this.
And then the charge is sort of--
the negative charge is sort
of floating around and sharing
those two centers,
like in H2 or Cl2.
I'm going to use Cl, so let's
keep using Cl, all right.
That would also be an
example of a covalent bond.
And the energy range there is
also quite large, 150 to 1100
are the numbers I got.
The attraction is shared
electrons-- shared pair
of electrons.
And I'm not putting
an R dependence,
because for covalent
bond, it's complicated.
It's complicated.
There is no.
It is.
It's a complicated-- but it's a
very nice, happy relationship.
But it's a complicated
R dependence.
So you can't simplify it
like you can with a 1 over R
or like some of the
other interactions
we'll talk about today.
OK.
1 over R, not for covalent.
All right.
Now that's where we've been.
Mm.
Here we go.
Look at this.
I'm not even-- I'm
just getting started.
Because the thing
is, now, we got
to talking about how
these molecules can
talk to each other.
And there's a variety of ways.
What I want to focus on
first is this thing here.
That's that polar covalent
bond that we've already
talked about.
So we've already got
a grounding for it.
Right.
But I want to remind
you of what happens.
Right.
So if I have, let's
keep with HCl.
If I have HCl,
that's a nice version
of a polar covalent bond.
And remember what happens
there is you've got
a sharing but sort of unfair.
Right.
So one of the atoms took a
little more of the charge.
And so sometimes
we represent that
with like a more of
the cloud, right,
on one side than the other.
But it's still a covalent bond.
Yeah.
But the thing is
that-- and so what
you're left with
like in this case
is some positive charge
on the hydrogen atom
and some negative charge
on the chlorine atom.
And we did this already.
We used these symbols.
And we also talked
about how that leads you
to a dipole moment.
What is a dipole?
Well, a dipole is
just the description
of what you have
in this case, where
you've got two charges of
opposite signs separated
by some distance.
OK.
Two charges.
Those aren't full charges.
Those are partial charges.
Right.
And they're separated by
some distance, the distance
between these two atoms.
And you get a dipole moment.
And it has a magnitude
and a direction.
And remember, just
to remind you,
I did share this with you
in a previous lecture.
But, you know, mu
equals the charge
times the distance
between the charge.
Right.
So that would be like the
charge would be the deltas here
and the distance between
them, right, would be this.
Right. 'r'.
Now, remember the
units are in Debye.
So for this molecule, for
here, mu is around 1.8D.
And 1D is equal to 3.3 times
10 to the minus 30th Coulomb
meters.
Those are the units.
Charge times distance.
Right.
OK.
3.3 times 10 to the minus
30th Coulomb meter is a Debye.
And again, just to remind you,
because we did talk about this
when we talked about
polar covalent bonds,
the dipole moment
of these molecules
tends to range from 0--
mm-- right there.
Right, no dipole, to 10 or so--
11.
Right.
Debyes.
Now, why is this important?
Because if you now think,
well, what would happen?
What would happen if I
brought another charge up
to the dipole?
What would happen?
Right.
Let's say that I bring
a positive charge.
Let's say that I'm
a sodium and I've
lost that outer electron, which
we know is pretty easy to lose,
if you're sodium.
Right.
So I'm positively in charged,
and I'm coming along,
and I see this dipole.
Well, it turns out that,
as you can imagine,
I'm going to be attracted
to that negative charge.
Right.
So this molecule's going
to orient in such a way
that I can actually
bond to the molecule
and be attracted to the
dipole of the molecule.
So that is actually
another type of bond.
Right.
And we'll call that ion-dipole.
It's an ion-dipole bond.
OK.
Let's do this so that I
stay within the lines.
All right.
Now, OK.
So what does that look like?
Well, we just said
it's a charge.
I'm taking a single
charge, and I'm bringing it
to this thing that has a
shift of the charge within it
that led to these
two partial charges.
So, as you as you
can imagine, it's
going to want to
orient to form a bond.
All right, so let's
draw it that way.
All right.
So maybe if I were
to take HCl, maybe I
would have sort of like,
you know, a cloud like that.
Right.
Where it had it's a minus
and it's plus there.
OK.
Why did I--
I don't know why used dash
lines, but there you go.
And so you can see that is--
what I wanted to put
is the dashed line
for the bond itself.
Give myself a little space.
Right.
That's the bond
we're talking about.
That's the bond we're talking--
Now, it turns out that
this is an important type
of interaction between
molecules and ions.
It's an ion dipole interaction.
And it has a range--
I wrote it down.
It has a range of 40 to
600, huge range, 40 to 600.
And the kind of
attraction is really not
describable in any other way
than what we just described.
It's an ion and a dipole.
And it goes as 1 over r squared.
If you look at the separation,
the distance between these,
right, that distance-- the
dependence on the energy,
on the bond energy, will
go like that distance,
like, 1 over that
distance squared.
Now, these dependencies
you can get from fairly
simple electrostatics.
I won't derive any of it.
I'm telling you what it is.
OK.
Good.
So an ion double--
now an example
of that would be the
system that I just drew.
Right.
So Na+ plus and HCl.
OK.
Good.
That's a different kind of bond.
But see, now, I could
also have two dipoles.
And I got a picture for that.
So here's a dipole.
There's my HCl
dipole, and there it
is with the negative
partial charge
and a positive partial charge.
And it's also color coded.
Right.
OK.
So that's cool.
And there they are
just floating along.
And I put an electric field on.
And you can see that
with the electric field--
so there's my positive plate
and my negative plate--
they're going to try to align.
Right.
These dipoles mean that they're
going to align with the field.
They're going to
align with the field.
So all of those
positive edges are
going to try to turn and
face the negative one.
And all those negative ones
are going to turn and face
the positive one.
And that's exactly what
we just did with this ion.
We basically did
the same thing here.
That's what the ion did.
OK.
It said, hey, come and face
me and let's form a bond.
But these can also be
attracted to each other.
All right.
And so I've got a picture there.
So you can see, like, if I have
a dipole in another dipole--
so this is not an external
field, and it's not an ion.
It's two dipoles,
two HCl molecules.
Right.
Well, they each have a plus
charge and a minus charge.
They each have a plus charge and
a minus charge and, you know,
partial charge,
right, polar covalent.
And you can see that those
can line up, actually,
in different ways
to form attraction.
And they can also repel.
Right.
But overall, when they get
together, or when two of them
get together, they're going
to find a way to attract,
because they can--
because they can.
And so that is another kind
of inter-molecular attraction,
and it's called a dipole-dipole.
Dipole-dipole.
But, let's draw this.
And if we do that we have--
let's see.
I'm going to try to draw this.
So I've got one dipole.
I'm going to stick
to that picture--
oh, I'm going to
stick to this picture,
but it's the same
as this picture,
right, where I'm actually
using the kind of shape
here to show you that
more charge has gone over
to one side.
OK.
So let's go back to here.
Right.
And so if that happens,
then I've got
minus and plus, thank you.
OK.
And then I'm going to have
another one that's going
to want to line up like this.
Oh.
Did I do that right?
Yeah.
And this is the bond.
This dashed line here
is the kind of bond
that we're talking about.
Yeah, those are almost
sort of asymmetric.
OK.
Now-- gesundheit.
Now, that's a dipole-dipole.
We don't really have a better
way of calling that either.
They're dipole
charges interacting
with dipole charges.
And that's going to give you
a 1 over r cubed dependence.
And, you know, if you've taken
some basic ENM or if you do,
you'll learn this.
Right.
You'll learn how to derive
these distance dependencies.
So I've got two dipoles,
right, because there are
two molecules that have not--
is not a non-polar.
It's a polar covalent bond.
And those are attracted
to each other in this way.
And the range of that bonding
strength for two dipoles
is 5 to 25.
So it's a lot less.
Right.
And well, if you had HCl and
HCl, that would be an example--
now instead of an ion, I'm
putting two polar molecules in.
Right.
So this could happen.
This could happen from a
molecule to a molecule.
It could happen from
an atom to a molecule.
a molecule to an atom.
Right.
So for example, you
know, I could have--
if I have HCl, and more charge
has gone to the chlorine side.
Right.
So this has my delta plus.
This is what I wrote
over on the other side.
That's my delta minus.
And if I have just
a single atom--
I'm going to put
a xenon atom here.
Well, it's just
sitting around happily,
you know, minding
it's own business.
And what's going
to happen to that?
Right.
What's going to happen to that?
Well, see, if this
comes up to an atom that
didn't have a dipole,
it still has feelings.
It still has feelings.
Why?
Because electrons have feelings.
That's why.
Because it has electrons.
So those electrons are in there,
and it doesn't have a dipole.
But that's OK, because those
electrons still can feel.
They can feel the
dipole of this.
dipole of this molecule.
And when they feel that
dipole, they react to it.
They react to it.
So there's a whole other
thing that can happen.
By the way, it could happen--
it could happen
with a sodium atom.
Na+ also is a charge that
this happy go lucky xenon,
it doesn't know what's coming.
But it's got electrons
that feel charge.
And so you bring
in charge to it,
and they're going
to react to it.
They're going to react to it.
Whether it's a single charge
or whether it's a dipole,
these are charges that
are going to change
the charge around that atom.
Now, there's another
name for that.
And that leads to
another kind of bond.
It actually leads to
Let's see.
So I'm going to just--
let me draw the cartoon.
I really want to make
sure you understand
this, because this sets up
the next kind of bonding.
And so let's suppose I take
a sodium, and I'll use H2.
H-- gesundheit.
H. And mine could have
been a single atom.
It could be a
non-polar molecule.
Right.
So this is what this looks like.
And now this is going to--
these are kind of
walking along happily,
and then they see each other.
And all of a sudden,
this is going
to induce a shift of the
charge around that H2 molecule.
So what you're going
to see is now more--
which way is it going to go?
Which should have the bigger
side, the more charge?
Right, yeah, here.
Because that's positive,
and electrons are negative.
So now it's going
to look like this.
Now, that was not a dipole.
It is not a molecule
with a dipole.
But it's an induced
dipole, induced dipole,
because of feelings.
It comes down to feelings.
That has a name.
All right.
That's ion.
that one right there
is ion-induced--
see if I can fit it all here--
induced dipole.
Ion-induced dipole.
And I'm going to try
to draw this now.
Let's see.
OK.
Hang on.
So the ion-induced dipole--
I'm going to have
a plus charge here,
and here's what I'm going to do.
I'm going to draw the
original shape as what it was.
Oh, boy.
Here we go.
That's what it was.
But then it got induced.
OK.
It got induced.
And so then, once
it's induced, you've
got like a minus and a plus.
Happens all the time.
It happens all the time.
Now, the way that it will--
we'll talk about this
in a little bit of
a different way,
because this attraction
is between an ion--
by the way, an ion just means an
atom or something lost a charge
or has a charge, plus or minus.
Remember, cation anion.
But the ion in this case
is interacting with what
is called a polarizable--
polarizable electron cloud.
Now, the electron
cloud is nothing new.
We got an electron cloud nailed.
We know about electron cloud.
Right.
Because those are orbitals.
But what is this thing
called polarizable?
Right, polarizable.
And that's a very
important term.
So I'm going to write
down its definition.
Because you can
imagine if I have
a way of being attracted
to a non-polar molecule
by shifting its charge, by
shifting its cloud, then
how easy was that?
How much could I shift it?
You can tell that that's going
to affect the bond strength.
By the way, which is--
let's see-- 3 to 15
and has a 1 over r
to the fourth dependence.
And let's give us-- let's give
the example that I gave there.
Na+ and H, H.
OK, non-polar molecule.
OK.
It could have been an atom.
But It could have been
a non-polar molecule.
Yeah.
Now, polarizable--
polarizability,
is a very important concept.
Polarizability is the measure--
gesundheit-- Of how easy it
is to temporarily distort
the electron distribution.
That is a very important
concept for these types of bonds
and for a lot of other
properties and, of course,
for life in general.
How polarizable
are my electrons?
I need to know.
Are they just willing to deform
from their happy orbitals?
Temporarily,
because if they were
going to deform
permanently, then you'd
have a dipole, a
permanent dipole.
These are induced dipoles.
OK.
That's important.
Now, OK, good.
So that's an ion-induced dipole.
Now you could also
imagine, you know,
this could have easily
been a dipole over here.
It didn't have to be an ion.
It could have been a dipole.
I could have had
a dipole here that
came up to a non-polar
molecule or an atom, right,
and it could have
induced the same shift
in the charge density, which
then allows me to be attracted,
because there's a little
bit of a fluctuation
of negative charge there.
Right.
So if I were to--
so the thing is, we've
been talking about dimers.
But you could talk about, what
is the dipole of something
more than a dimer.
So this is polar.
What about these other things?
Right.
So if I look at molecules,
right, that are polar,
it's not just about
HCl, right, which
is that first one up there.
But that's kind of
the obvious case.
But what about CCl4?
What if I take a carbon
atom and I put 4 chlorines?
Those are all polar bonds.
And you can see-- well, it's
hard to see-- but they've
drawn in the dipole moment.
You've lost some
charge from the carbon.
It's gone out to
the chlorine atom.
There's a dipole movement
within each bond.
But now here's where
VSEPR comes in,
because these are going to
be tetrahedrally distributed
and fully canceling out.
So it's like you've
got all these kind
of electrostatic things
going on that all cancel out.
So this molecule is
not a polar molecule.
Right.
On the other hand,
molecules NH3 or CH3Cl--
right.
Now, this is going to be polar,
because these dipoles do not
cancel out within the molecules.
So you can kind of
use this thinking.
There's BF3, trigonal planar.
Right.
All those dipoles cancel.
It's a non-polar molecule.
But if you take a
classic example--
which we'll come back--
of, say, water as
a polar molecule,
I could do the same thing.
Right.
I can take water, which
is oxygen, hydrogen,
hydrogen. And you see you've
got delta plus there, delta
plus there, and you've
got some minus there.
Right.
Now, there's a dipole
moment, so part of it cancels
but not all of it.
So there is a dipole moment
for the net water molecule.
The net dipole is what
matters to determine
if a molecule's polar or not.
So there's a net
dipole, net dipole
when you sum them all up.
And that's what's
going to determine
if this can come along to
that xenon atom, right.
And so here's my xenon just
sitting there doing nothing.
And now when water comes up to
xenon, what's going to happen?
Well, what's going
to happen is I've
got my water molecule, my
water molecule, my delta minus,
my delta plus, my delta plus.
And because it's
got a net dipole,
it's going to form the atom.
And so I'm going to have--
let's see, make sure
I draw this right.
So it's going to look
kind of like this.
Delta minus, delta plus, and
that allows a water molecule
to bond to a xenon atom.
It is bonding with another
bond, which is very
similar to what I just wrote--
gesundheit-- But it is a
dipole-induced, not ion.
It is a dipole-induced dipole.
You see that?
Because now, I
didn't have an ion.
I had a water molecule
that had a dipole moment.
So now I've got my
dipole-induced dipole,
and that's going to look--
oh let's draw it.
Let's see.
So I got my
dipole-induced dipole.
So we're going to go, kind
of, oh, boy, there we go.
OK.
Minus, plus, and then--
now that might be the
dipole of, say, the water
molecule or something that.
And then I've got another thing
that didn't have a dipole,
but it got induced to have one.
OK.
Oh, boy.
I went out of the lines.
Ah.
I was so careful.
But you can't-- you
can't hold chemistry.
Uh-uh.
No way.
Mm.
OK.
Delta plus, delta
minus, it's induced.
That's what that means, right.
Now, it turns out that
this has an even weaker--
so this would be a dipole.
Let's just-- right,
let's finish this up--
dipole interacting with the
polarizable electron cloud.
And the value of this is
even lower range, 2 to 10,
and the dependence is
1 over r to the sixth.
And the example--
let's go back to HCl.
HCl, there's my
dipole coming in ClCl.
I like that because
it's got three Cls.
Why not?
That's a non-polar molecule.
That's a dipole.
That induces a dipole
in this by shifting
its polarized electrons around.
Right.
And then it allows there to
be a little bit of attraction.
You might be saying,
but that's so little.
We'll get to that in a second.
That's not so little.
That's actually not so little
when you've got a lot of it.
OK.
Dipole interaction-- now
it turns out that even--
and this is what's mind blowing.
You knew this was coming.
This moment today
was going to come.
I can have an interaction
without any dipole
to start with.
It's true.
I can take two
non-polar covalent
bonds, two non-polar covalent
molecules, H2 and H2,
and they are attracted
to each other.
How is that possible?
Well, it's what explains this.
I mean, we know--
why does helium,
argon, and xenon--
why do these have
different boiling points?
By the way, the boiling
point of these--
all right, so these can
be made into liquids
and you can boil them, right--
is really different.
And it's a measure of
how strongly they're
bonded together.
Right.
So this is a direct kind
of way of thinking about,
of measuring something that's
related to the bond strength.
So why do these atoms--
they're all just atoms--
you know, they're
all just like this.
They don't have this dipole.
Right.
They're non-polar.
They're just atoms sitting there
with their symmetric charge
clouds.
How is it that they
can be attracted
to each other in
the first place?
And how is it that they can
have such a strong trend?
And that has to do with
another kind of force.
And there is a picture.
So here's two examples.
There's two helium atoms.
So that's the first one in
this list, boiling point
minus 269 degrees Celsius.
It's pretty cold.
And there's two
non-polar molecules, H2.
What happens is that
you get fluctuations.
You get fluctuations.
And what I mean by that is
that, just randomly, literally,
randomly, right, because of
collisions or thermal energy--
randomly, one of those
could form a dipole.
I didn't mean it.
It wasn't my happy
place, but it happened.
Now, if it happens and
your charge kind of
goes to one side, even if
it's just for a split second,
that's a dipole that then,
if you're near another atom,
can induce a dipole.
And we know that if we can
induce a dipole, if we're here,
if we're at this stage, we've
already got that covered.
We already know that I
can induce another dipole
if I'm charged.
Right.
And so what happens is you
get this kind of fluctuation
that leads literally to a bond.
It leads to a bond.
Right.
And that is called
London dispersion.
That's called the London force,
and the London dispersion
is the name of a kind
of bonding you have.
Let me just make sure--
ha.
OK.
London dispersion.
Notice there's
room for one more.
It's coming.
There's more.
We're not done.
We are not done.
I can literally take two
non-polar atoms or molecules,
and I can find a way for
them to be attracted.
And the way it happens
is thermal fluctuations.
This is such an important force,
and it's such a strange one
that I want to write
down what it is.
It's that non-polar-- we've
been talking about polar
and charges, but
non-polar molecules
are attracted by fluctuations.
Fluctuations.
I should say, by
dipole fluctuations.
That's really what's happening.
Right.
By dipole fluctuations.
So one of them gets a little
shift, and there's a dipole.
And then that dipole, if
there's another one around,
can induce a shift, and
then there can be a bond.
And now, this gets back to
something very important,
which is that--
you can imagine, how easy
was it for temperature--
how easy was it to
create that shift?
Right.
Well that's going to have to
do with your polarizability.
Now, OK, so what is it that
has to do with polarizability?
Right.
Well, if-- oh, I do
have a board here.
Ha.
OK.
You can already imagine, if
I go back to this list here--
if I go from helium to
argon, what have I done?
I've gone down in
the periodic table.
And we've already
talked about this.
Those electrons that are going
to do the shifting to cause
the fluctuation--
those electrons are
more loosely bound.
Right.
They're further out.
They're more loosely bound.
We've already talked about this.
We've looked at this
in a lot of ways.
Right.
Whether it's radius or
ionization energy, those are--
if they're more loosely
bound, then they're
easier to shift around.
I'm not taking them out.
Right.
But I'm moving them.
That's what London is.
I got to fluctuate it.
So you can imagine now,
why, if it's heavier,
and those electrons are further
out, they're more polarizable.
Right.
So let's write that down.
So the London-- so we're going
to get a stronger London--
two reasons.
One, heavier atom, which
really, in this case,
right, it's heavier,
but it really
just means more polarizable.
If it's more polarizable,
that's the key.
That's the chemistry key, more
polarizable, more polarizable
electron cloud.
Write it all out.
But the other thing that you
can imagine with London--
right, so that
explains that trend.
The other thing that you
can imagine with London
is that these interactions,
these fluctuations, they're
happening all over the place.
And the more contact I have--
the more places in a molecule
I have to induce this,
to have this fluctuation happen,
the stronger these forces
could be.
And this is exactly what we see.
Look at this trend.
Methane, ethane,
propane, and butane.
All I've done is I've
added another carbon atom.
Oh, we're going to get to these.
We'll talk a little
bit about Orgel later.
But for now, look at the
boiling points of those.
Again, boiling point being a
proxy for the bonding strength.
What bond could they have?
None of those, only this.
Ha.
I got excited.
Only in London, because look,
they're non-polar molecules.
They've got no charge on them.
This is the only way they
can talk to each other.
But look at how much
they talk to each other.
Now, why?
Because of the
second thing, right.
Which is that the
greater the surface,
the greater the surface.
You can have more.
The more surface you have--
the greater surface,
more contact area,
more contact area.
And that's how this bond--
that's how this thing works.
Because as long as I've got
more surfaces see each other,
then there can be more
fluctuations, right,
that are happening, that
then induce the other one
to have a fluctuation,
that then create
a little moment of
bonding, that dramatically
changes the properties.
And look at this.
This is a little bit small,
but, you know, these are the--
so let's go all the way, right.
CH4, OK.
Let's go all the way,
and look at this.
It determines when you have
a gas at room temperature
or when you have a liquid
at room temperature.
Boy, is that important for
how we use these molecules.
Right.
Boy, is that important.
It's all London.
there's no other option.
Right.
But that's what's
dictating this trend.
It's even more mind-blowing
than that, because look at this.
This is one molecule
that's identical.
This is C5.
This is 5 atoms of
carbon, n-Pentane.
Same exact grams per mole,
because it's the same chemical
formula.
But look here, 36.1 degrees
C is the boiling point,
and here it's 9.5.
Why?
It's all this.
This is not the ground state.
The most stable
structure is here.
But there is a version
that's called neopentane.
It's like a nickname for it.
There's a version of
it that you can make
that has a different shape.
And because this shape cannot
come into contact with itself,
look at this, you can
see it from the red line.
It's coming into
contact with itself.
In the liquid or gas, it can't
have as much London forces,
London potential.
So it cannot bind as strongly,
and therefore the boiling point
is a lot lower.
It's a lot lower.
Now, there's a little
bit of naming confusion.
I want to clear this up.
Oh, boy.
I have nowhere to go here.
So I'm going to get rid
of London for a second.
And I want to make
something very clear
that there's another
word that's used,
which is called Van der Waals.
OK.
Now, this ability of a
fluctuation to happen,
which then induces
a fluctuation, that
can happen no matter
what molecule you have.
It can happen.
And it does.
It's always there.
All right.
So all molecules, whether
they are polar or non-polar--
polar or non-polar, all
molecules are attracted
by London plus any other
attractive forces--
any other attractive
forces present--
forces present.
OK.
So London is always there.
Now, people interchangeably
use the term Van der Waals.
And what Van der
Waals encompasses
is more than London.
Van der Waals, what you will
sometimes see in textbooks,
is the Van der Waals force.
OK.
So that is any or
all added together.
This is the combination of these
weak forces of dipole-dipole--
dipole-dipole.
Let's see, dipole-induced
dipole, and London.
Those taken together
you will sometimes
see referred to as Van der
Waals forces, or weak forces.
But we know more than that.
We know the distinction.
Right.
We know that London started like
this and then went like this.
Ah!
Really bad.
Gesundheit.
Right.
We know that it
started with non-polar,
and that there's a difference.
And so this is all about the
polarizable electron cloud.
Polarizable electron
cloud, that's all you got.
Right.
And this can be really
small, 0.5 to 40.
Oh, yeah.
Let's just keep with
chlorine 2, chlorine 2.
Two non-polar molecules,
London dispersion,
and this also has
a dependence of--
in terms of the distance--
of 1 over r to the sixth.
Now, in case you
think that's small,
I want to show you a little
video of why this matters.
So weak forces-- now, weak
forces are really strong.
We know this because of
"Mission: Impossible".
We know this also because
of our own students.
There was one of my
former students, Rory,
and he won all sorts
of prizes, because he
was trying to be like a gecko.
And so he made gloves that
were like gecko gloves,
and much to the delight of
the facilities people at MIT,
he actually climbed one of the
buildings using his gloves.
In case you are wondering, it
wasn't actually their delight.
But really cool stuff.
So let me show you.
This is like a 30-second video.
He found the answer in the sheer
number and design of the hairs
on the geckos feet.
Geckos have millions
of microscopic hairs
on their toes.
And of course, we can't see
this with our naked eye,
because each hair is only
1/10 the size of a human hair.
And each of those hairs
branch down to billions
of little split ends.
And they can make such close
contact with the surface
that weak intermolecular
forces can begin to add up
to something really strong.
Turns out geckos exploit
something called the Van der
Waals force.
No.
London, London.
If you think of an atom
as a dancing couple,
when you bring two atoms
into very close contact,
part of one atom can get
attracted to part of the other.
That very weak bond is
the Van der Waals force,
and it sticks atoms together.
Proximity is the key.
But bringing two materials
that near each other
is harder than you'd think.
All right.
Now, obviously, that
got me very excited
when I saw that, because
that is how I see atoms,
and that is how I see electrons.
And I saw this, and
I almost fell over.
And of course, I played it,
and I know all those moves.
I would suggest you guys--
it's a Friday.
There's some good
moves in there.
And you can take
this on your phone
and just kind of work
it out at the club.
And speaking of
the club, there's
one more thing I've
got to teach you.
Because it's that last line.
It's that last line.
See, if you go along a trend
like methane, silane, germane,
right, these are
non-polar molecules,
and they're all
attracted to each other
by these Van der Waals.
And you can see that the
boiling point, remember,
our proxy for the force, the
bonding strength, is going up.
That's what you'd expect.
That's because these
are getting larger,
and there are going to be
more polarizable electrons.
But look at what happens as
you go to other molecules.
This is the expected
trend until you get here.
Right.
NH3-- and that is because
of one last type of bond.
That is because of something
called the hydrogen bond.
It's a very unique kind of bond.
And so a hydrogen bond is
our last intermolecular bond.
Hydrogen bond, right.
And it's a very
particular kind of bond.
And it has to do is
something very particular
that hydrogen does.
Look at those boiling points.
Look at the change.
I mean, H2O is H2O because
of the hydrogen bonds.
Right.
Earth's operating conditions
are luckily right here.
But this is only good
because of hydrogen bonds,
and it's all the way up and
not all the way down there.
So hydrogen bonds are unique.
This is the
electronegativity scale,
and there's something
very important
that happens for
those three elements.
Those are the three elements
that are in this trend.
Those are the three elements.
See, nitrogen, chlorine,
and oxygen, those
are the three elements here.
And what's important
about them is
that they have such a
huge electronegativity.
And so in a hydrogen bond,
what's going to happen--
what's going to
happen in a hydrogen
is they're really going
to pull a lot of charge
from the hydrogen.
So you have a very high
positive charge on the hydrogen,
but there's something
else that happens.
For hydrogen bonding
to occur, you see,
it's the H with say
fluorine, and you
have a delta plus and a delta
minus, and this is high.
This is very high.
All right.
But you also have a
lone pair somewhere.
You've also got a
And we know that we have
that on the fluorine, right.
We know that, and
we've got those two.
And the bond that a
hydrogen bond represents
is the fact that I've done two
things with the same molecule.
I've taken a lot of
charge off of hydrogen
and created a very strong
delta plus on the hydrogen.
But I've also got a
lone pair somewhere
that that can bond to.
And when I have those two
things, which I really
have for these three
elements, right.
When I have those two things, I
can make this very special kind
of bond.
Now, this is what it looks like.
Right.
So there's an H2O molecule, and
I want to make a point here.
There's the covalent
bond between the oxygen
and hydrogen. There's
the delta plus.
And there's that hydrogen
bond right there.
Mm.
There.
OK.
Hydrogen bond that forms
between the delta plus
and the lone pair.
Now, you can see why
water is so special.
You can see.
Because unlike
NH3 or HF, you can
see where water had
the biggest kick
up from what would be expected.
Because unlike NH3 or HF, you
have exactly the right balance.
I've created two of these
very strong delta pluses,
and I've got two lone pairs.
It all all works out.
There's no extra lone
pairs, like here.
And all these extra lone
pairs, right, that don't--
you know, each molecule
only has one hydrogen. Here,
it's two and two.
That's why water is so special.
This bond is so important.
I know you've probably
heard about it for water,
but here's the example I want
to give you for the club,
because some of you might
be able to drink ethanol,
only if you're at the right
age, please, of course.
This is what's in
alcohol, right.
This is the ethanol molecule.
And it has a boiling
point of 78.5 degrees.
Again, that tells you something
about the bond strength
of this molecule to
another molecule.
But look at this.
That's an oxygen
with a hydrogen.
This took a lot of
charge from the hydrogen,
right, so you've got
a strong delta plus.
But you've got those
two lone pairs there
ready to bond to the
other ethanol molecule.
But look what happens.
Methoxymethane is
a gas at room temp.
It's boiled off.
It's the exact same
chemical formula.
All I've done is
shift the oxygen in,
and so now there's
no hydrogen that's
had that big of a delta on it.
So it cannot hydrogen bond.
It can London.
You know.
But it can't hydrogen. It can't.
Because the oxygen
has the lone pairs.
But there's no hydrogens that
have that strong of a delta.
So when you're at
the club tonight,
trying out those moves,
go up to somebody
and say, it's a really
good thing that's
not methoxymethane, isn't it.
Really good thing.
And tell them about
hydrogen bonds.
Have a great weekend.